c'est l'acte 2 du rapprochement entre
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine de
nouvelles compétences seront
prochainement mutualiser la commande
publique et l'éducation avec notamment
une gestion interdépartementale des 214
collège des départements bien entendu il
n'y aura pas de fermeture du collège
bien entendu il n'y aura pas moins
d'effectifs dans les collèges cette
administration centrale ce qu'on appelle
l'administration centrale que la
convergence se fera nous pensons là
aussi que leurs rassemblements de c2c
direction pourra nous permettre de faire
mieux avec moins
cet objectif a motivé la création de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental en février 2016
actuellement 45% des compétences
départementales sont communes et les
deux collectivités s'inspire l'une de
l'autre
nous avons constaté que le
service des yvelines fonctionnait bien
qu'il donnait de bons résultats en tous
les cas que c'était mieux que ce que
nous faisons donc d'y a pas de problème
nous adhérons à activity en unifiant ses
nouveaux services les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine veulent rendre
irréversible leur fusion même si le
gouvernement n'a pas rendu d'avis
concernant la création d'une seule
collectivité